how old is the universe can you dig in
onto this number how do we know
currently with those I guess you said
four or five significant uh digits so we
can come about it from two different
ways one basically they rely on the most
important number in cosmology which is
called the Hubble constant the Hubble
constant is this weird number that has
the following units it has the units of
kilometers per second per megaparsec so
it's a speed per distance which means
you multiply it by distance and you get
a speed and what is the speed you're
measuring well you're measuring the
speed of a distant Galaxy at many
megaparsecs away so a Galaxy at one Mega
particular this isn't actually strictly
true because of local gravitational
effects but if you go out say one Mega
parsecore I would say that that Galaxy's
moving 72 kilometers per second away
from you and every Galaxy except for the
local very most local group surrounding
us maybe a half a dozen galaxies out of
500 billion galaxies to perhaps a
trillion galaxies so 12 out of that
number are moving towards us the rest
are moving away from us
[Music]